bu
daha doğmadan başladı Aslında Hikayemiz
çocuk birini çocuğu olmaya çalıştık ilk
başta üstümüzde ardından cinsiyetine
göre kılıfları sokuldu yüzümüze kadın ya
da erkek olup
[Müzik]
abone ol
o böyle yoğun bir şekilde cinsiyeti
kalıplarla beraber hesabımızdan kulları
büyük çıktı En azından bunları duysam da
bu tarafa insanda bu kalıpları aşmanın
yollarını aradın
Ama bu benim için de bir söylemde
çıkacaksın Çünkü ben ilacın Aynen
babamla ya da ablamdan hali üzerinden
durumu
ne yaptın Annemler de oturuyorduk
bu beden çayını doldurmak için hat
O bana dedi ki siz ne yapıyorsunuz Deniz
erkek haline kalmış çayını dolduruyor
Siz kız ayrıldı oturuyorsunuz
O benim annem de daha çok böyle bir
çocukları duymayan dokunursam Hayat şu
nasıl yakın artık eşittir diyen çocuğu
olarak bildiğim için de benim hayırlısı
ya da kalmıştır Ama bu kalıbı artık beni
haline getiren kişiler Bunları kabul
etmiş burada
Ya ben aslında ben İçindeki çocuklardan
tadı nasıl duruyor buranın temellerinden
de böyle kırmızı yollarını anlatacağım
birkaç tane erkek özellikle etkisinden
bahsetmek istiyorum erkekler için
oluşturan kollara baktığımız zaman daha
çok erkekleri düzeltme kadar kırıldığını
görebiliriz sözüneri Adamın dibi elim
adım ya insanın bir kızlar yapılır
var bunun yanı sıra erkeklerin etrafında
yarar iletişimde düzen kalıplar var
mesela Erkekler Ağlamaz yedikler bir
sürü çocuk görebiliriz etrafımızda topun
erkeklere sürekli olarak ağlayacağına
öldüremeyeceğini dik durması gerektiğini
ve çalışması gerektiğini söyle açıkçası
bir akşam annemle babam salonda film
izliyorlardı Ben salona gittim ilk
olarak annemi gördüm annem ağlıyor Bu
benim çok alıştım görsen Çünkü annem en
komik filmleri ağlayabilecek Ozan söyle
sahip Sonra baktım ama almıyor ve on
durup Kendi kendime düşündüm Dedim ki
hani Erkekler Ağlamaz dış Çünkü toplum
bugüne kadar bana dedi ki Erkekler
Ağlamaz Ama babam etrafında çizilen
sınırı açmıştı Peki babam artık erkek
olmaktan çıkmış mıydı Ya aslında Erkek
dediğin yavaşlayan cümlelerin hepsinde
kişilerin Kendi öz güvensizlikler yatar
erkeklerin alabileceğiniz ayrı film
kesildi görmek istiyorum
Bu
Kalbim kırık bir şekilde kaldım düşünün
bütün milletlerin Marşı çalındı ama biz
ince
Bizimki
bayrağımız bire Çünkü o
[Müzik]
ve bu hata ki toplum yapısını kadın
üzerindeki etkisinden bahsetmek
istiyorum birazcık burada kalıplar
sadece ülkemizde değil malev fazla
Pakistan İran gibi cinsiyetçiliğin çok
yüksek olduğu ülkelerde görülüyor Fas'ta
kadınların işgücüne katılımı yüzde yirmi
yedi Ürdün'de yüzü 16 iken Türkiye'de
kalın istihdam oranı erkeklere oranına
bakıldığında yarısından daha az olduğu
görülmüş buradaysa toplum bize diyor ki
kadın çalışmaz Ben de burada Durak
diyorum ki kadında çalışır kadınla
gelişir benim annemle Teyzem de bir anım
var kadın bir misafir geldi ya da birini
ağırladığı zaman Fix bütün şudur gelir
yemeği hazırlar sofrayı kurar erkek
kadın beraber sofraya oturur yemeklerini
yerler erkek geçer oturur kadın bir
telaş içine girer işte sofrayı
toplayayım bulaşıkları İki tatlı servis
çay servisi yapayım ben anneme Dedim ki
anne dedim Şu an ne oluyor çünkü sen
bana Sabahtan beri diyorsun ki ya bu
yanlış şunu getir çay götür çayı getir
erkekler niye oturuyor anne dedim annem
bunun üzerine Bana bak ara dedi ki
Yağmur sen İlerideki hayat arkadaşına
böyle der Sen evde kaldım aslında bir
kadının tek meziyeti evlenmek değildir
toplum tarafından kadın sürekli olarak
işte kadına mühendis bilim insanı
olurmuş Deniz ama kadının bilimdeki
yerine görememek yapacağımız en büyük
köylülerden biri olur mavi küre azebet
Black böyle sefer ya özel ya da korna
töreninde daha fazla tanıdığımız eşiyle
beraber biyotik resmi geliştiren Dr
Özlem süreci verebileceğiniz sayısı
örneklerden bazıları
diğer iki toplum kabul etti Dedi ki
Kadın çalışır ama şimdi Bir de diyor ki
Kadın çalışır ama yaptığı işi kız gibi
yapar kız gibi yapmakla alakalı bir
ekran filmi izlemek istiyorum
abone ol
ha ha yağın Hay
Okey gibisin akşam video o
[Müzik]
la la
bu
Annenizi karı önem tenis oldu o
[Alkış]
bugün
burada kalacağım
Hayır ya
Ha bu arada miyim diye ona yeter bana
kadar o o
bu Nil Karaibrahimgil'in kız gibi yapmak
adlı bir TED konuşması var Orada diyor
ki bizim cinsiyetimiz ne zamandan beri
diğerleri için bir hakaret haline geldi
kız gibi yapmak kız gibi koşmak kız gibi
fırlatmak ne zamandan beri hakaret oldu
aslında tarihimizin emsali görülmeyen
savaşlarına baktığımızda Çanakkale
Savaşı'nda kadınların kız gibi savaşmak
için Cemre erkek kılığına girdiğini
görüyoruz ya da kız gibi yapmak için
cümle mermi taşıdığını görüyoruz ben
burada sarı soru sormak istiyorum siz
kız gibi yaparak neyi başardınız bu
kadar büyük bir şey olmasına gerek yok
ben kız gibi yaparak burada hepinizin
beni dinlemesini sağlıyorum
bu peki Aslında bu kalıpların temelleri
nasıl oluşur diye sorarsak en basitinden
Eğitim gördüğümüz ders kitaplarına
baktığım zaman bir sürü şey görebiliriz
Ben burada Tolga Hocam ve Zeynep'le
beraber Twitter için hazırladığımız ve
bize bölge birinciliği kazandıran
temizlik coğrafya konu Başlıklı Kız'ın
coğrafyası projemizden birkaç albümün
kullandım İlk başta bana coğrafya ders
kitabı inceleme gerektiği söylendi zaman
diyordum ki ya Ne olabilir ki en fazla
aynı daha ta iş tepeoba Harita ama en
beklemediğiniz Yani bir sürü cinsiyetçi
ifade edilen görsel bulduk erkeği Doktor
işin sonu mühendis olarak gösterildiği
yerde kadın tarım işçisi halı dokumacısı
tekstilde çalışan ya da öğretmen kişi
olarak gösterilmişti iüs tarafa
baktığımızda ise nüfus piramidi ile
karşılaşıyoruz hani şey yapabilirsiniz
Ne var ki bunda Çünkü artık çok alıştık
kadının pembe erkeği mavi ile
gösterilmesine çok alıştık biz bu
projemizin sunumlarını yaparken bir bu
günümüzde dedi ki bunun farkında
getirmeniz çok güzel olmuş renkleri
kalıpları yoktur dedi ama dedim ben
erkek oğlum yani oğlum Ha dedi pembe
giydirmem Aslında biz burada bu
kalıpların hayatımız olan etkisi ile
karşılaşıyoruz
Biz bunu sadece ülkemizde değil
Bulgaristan ve mu acisan gibi ülkelerde
de görüyoruz bunun yanı sıra Avustralya
baktığımızda Enginev iş yaptığı erkek ve
kadının beraber Çocuğa bak fotoğraflarla
karşılaştık
bunları yıkamanın bir diğer yolu ise en
büyük iletişim araçlarımızdan biri olan
dilimizi yapacağınız küçük değişiklikler
olur biz bu değişiklikleri yapmadıkça
Aslında çocukların birbirinin farklı
olmasını bekleyemeyiz
karşımıza birbirinin farklı olan
çocukların çıkar yoksa 1984 romandaki
gibi tek Fikret'i düşünce monoton bir
hayat mı çıkar diye soruyorum ben burada
kendime
Aslında biz Ondan sonra birbirimizden
farklı olmaya korkarız biz bir kere 8
sınıfta oturuyorduk sınıfta olacak yerde
tahtaya bir soru açtım 4 ışık var ABC
dedi ki çözün herkese sıra cevabını
söylemeye başladı işte ben a buldum A
buldum ben ama bulamamıştım Aslında ben
de buldum hocaya söylemedim Çünkü ben
farklıydım farklı olmak beni korkutuyor
tek Ben yanlışım ben yanlış buldum Hoca
soru çözdükten sonra Aslında doğru
cevabını de olduğu ortaya çıktı
kalıpların hayatımıza etkisini burada
görüyoruz Diyoruz ki ben farklıysan
farklı katılım yapamam yeni bir adım
atamam fikrimi söylemem diyoruz denize
yapacağımızı küçük değişikliğe
geçtiğimizde ise en basitinden cinsiyet
ifadeleri kullanmamalıyız sözüneri demek
yerine sözünü sağlık güvenilir demeliyiz
hanım hanımcık demek yerine kibar görgü
ödemeyi tercih edebiliriz ya da en çok
kullandığımız bilim adamı demek yerine
bilim insanı demeyi tercih edebiliriz
Ben Açıkçası bu dilimizde oluşan
kalıpların kişilerin Kendi öz güven
sevdiklerinden ve Aslında önyargıları
oluştuğunu anladım bu projeyi
hazırlarken
ben burada diyorum ki bu kişilerin
fikirlerinin tercihlerini duygularını
yok sayan görmezler gelen kalıpları
kullanmamalıyız ben bu da sadece s
gözündeki perdeyi göstermek bu perde da
onlardan oluştuğunu anlatmak için vardım
bu perdeyi kaldırıp gözünüzün önünde
güzel hayatı görmek size kalmış bir
durum sonra da şunu söylemek istiyorum
Nasıl konuşursak öyle düşünürüz biz bu
söylemleri değiştirmedikçe ayağımızdaki
zincirlerle yaşamaya mahkumuz Bu yüzden
bu kadınları kullanmamalıyız beni
dinlediğiniz ve sesini duyduğum için
teşekkür ederim